sure a lot of found-footage horror films
might leave you sneezing but there are
still a few gems worth watching from
obscure flicks to landmark films these
are the found footage horror movies that
are actually good
in 2007 chill Mabel egg arrow and Paco
Plaza set out to make a horror film that
would bring audiences further into the
action than ever before Bella garel told
IGN that their goal is to make their
audience feel as though they were a part
of the film itself explaining we wanted
to use the film screen in a way that is
similar to the experience of playing
video games rec does exactly that using
a single camera the film follows a
reporter along a story that begins as a
daily life expose of some firemen and
ends with them trapped in an apartment
building that gets quarantined by the
government as the night progresses the
reason for the quarantine becomes
terrifyingly obvious rec doesn't hold
back when it comes to scaring its
audience the film throws itself into
horror almost immediately and stays
there for the remainder of its 80 minute
runtime it's short not so sweet and to
the point it doesn't try to be anything
other than a shocker and in that regard
it completely succeeds Barry Levinson
isn't the first name that comes to mind
when it comes to film footage horror
films in 2012 Levinson co-wrote and
directed the bay a found footage film
that is about as far from his usual
repertoire as a film can get the bay
documents a fourth of July incident in
Claridge Maryland that took the lives of
700 of its residents through webcams
phone videos and recorded calls to
emergency services details emerge
regarding the parasitic outbreak that
affected everything in the Bay this is
dr. Williamson communicable disease you
believe you may have a bacterial case
what as far as phone footage goes the
bay has more production value than most
it looks and feels like the real deal
which is only amplified by a solid story
with a legitimate social message and a
cast that knows what they're doing
essentially the film is nowhere near
amateur and getting through the entire
thing will actually make your skin crawl
in 2007 Oren Peli made Paranormal
Activity a film about a couple who
experienced strange things in their new
home
naturally they decided to try and solve
the supernatural mystery
by setting up cameras throughout the
house what they find is beyond creepy
and things only get worse the more they
try and document the source of their
misery Paranormal Activity is one of
those horror films that leaves most of
its terror to the unknown lights go on
and off in the background doors move and
the sheets are pulled by an invisible
force all of this goes on mostly on the
notes of the film's main characters so
watching it happen while waiting to see
if it wakes them up turns into an
exercise of how long you can really hold
your breath the ending is also one of
the better final scares any horror film
has had in decades whether it be through
gore shock value or the regular creep
factor the point that most found-footage
horror films trying to make is that
somewhere there is something that is
absolutely terrifying and you should be
very very afraid troll hunter isn't
really like that the 2010 Norwegian film
is scary yes but it's also incredibly
funny and it's chock-full of giant
killer trolls Andre overdog created a
film that stays true to its roots in
folklore set in a very modern world
steeped in cynicism when a group of film
students discovered the government has
been hiding the existence of trolls
along the Norwegian countryside they
take it upon themselves to document the
creatures visually troll hunter looks
modern and well produced but the film is
90% improvisation so what you see on the
screen is done mostly on the fly it all
works though and the movie winds up
being one of the most entertaining found
footage films in recent years VHS is an
okay movie the 2010 found-footage horror
anthology had some originality in a few
scares but it fell into the category of
mostly forgettable 2000s horror the year
later VHS 2 came out and while most
sequels tend to be far worse than the
original this sequel happens to be one
of those rare finds that surpasses its
predecessor in nearly every way
that doesn't mean VHS 2 is without its
flaws not every one of its five horror
stories is a winner but the ratio of
those that are makes the film worth your
time the biggest standout is safe haven
by Teemo giant oh and Gareth Evans the
former wrote and directed the night
comes for us while the latter wrote and
directed the raid - and the raid
redemption safe haven delves into death
cults demonic worship and zombies making
it not only one of the most well rounded
horror stories of the bunch but one of
the creepiest as well Deborah Logan
suffers from an aggressive form of
Alzheimer's in order to save their home
from being repossessed her daughter
Sarah convinces Deborah to allow a
documentary crew to film her as part of
an Alzheimer's study alright I have fun
right okay good
further along they get into their study
however the more obvious it becomes that
Deborah may be suffering from something
that isn't at all based in science while
the premise may not be anything new or
especially progressive the taking of
Deborah Logan's draw isn't its plot this
particular possession story is less
about rituals and sacrifice and more
about watching Deborah slowly devolve
into something not quite human in the
most nightmarish ways lead actress Jill
Larson definitely carries the film but
it also benefits from his truly creepy
visuals throughout that make the taking
of Deborah Logan a worthwhile horror
experience in 2013 real-life best
friends Derek Lee and Clif Prowse II set
out to reinvigorate the found footage
horror genre with their feature film
debut afflicted
the film follows a semi-fictional
version of the pair as they embark on a
one-year journey around the world but
are stopped short when a one-night stand
transforms Leigh into something
unimaginable the dual told Collider that
their goal with afflicted was to focus
on the store and to allow the found
footage aspect of the movie to work only
in their budgetary favor Lee explains
this was a character-driven heartfelt
but still fun and technically possible
film that we could shoot for less than a
million dollars afflictive winds up
being just that a character-driven
horror film about the morality of
becoming something other than human it's
well shot in the effects stand up even
in spite of its weaker budget more than
anything though the
Filmworks not by using cheap jump scares
but by focusing on the story itself as
well as the relationship between the two
best friends who are trapped in a
foreign land there's something
especially creepy about the idea of a
cycle lurking around on Craigslist
that's the premise for 2014's creep
which stars Mark Duplass as Joseph a man
who claims to be dying and wants to
create a video series for us unborn son
he hires Aaron to film and things get
really really weird your first time
creep explores our need to be polite in
social situations and how that knee can
come at the price of our own safety
Joseph seems to be a kind and genuine
person but anyone can seem to be
anything when there's someone you know
from the internet the film isn't gory
and it doesn't over rely on jump scares
instead creep finds a way under your
skin because Duplass is so incredible at
playing someone who comes off as both
sincere and mildly repugnant and then
there's that line that aaron is afraid
to cross shouldn't he heard Joseph's
feelings and leave this weirdo behind or
should he put up with the guys
increasing creepiness sure the lightness
has its place but a remote cabin in the
woods
isn't it hell house LLC takes the idea
of an haunted house and mashes it into a
found-footage nightmare in the best way
possible the 2015 film tells the story
of the Hell House a New York city-based
Halloween attraction that sets up shop
at an abandoned hotel in a small town of
Abaddonn New York after 15 attendees and
nearly the entire crew are found dead
the morning after opening night the
series of tapes lays out the truth of
what actually happened inside although
the film suffers a bit from a story that
we've seen a million times before hell
house LLC finds a way to scare its
audience and it's through some pretty
clever placement throughout the house
monsters come in and out of frame but
not in an outright jump in front of the
camera sort of way instead they tend to
hide in the shadows barely visible for a
moment or two before they disappear
completely it's nerve-racking trying to
keep track of them and it's exactly that
feeling that makes the movie a
successful horror flick the conspiracy a
2012 horror film that definitely isn't
real feels like it could totally be real
that's the thing about conspiracy movies
though you're left questioning
everything you've just seen even if all
of it is made up for the sake of
terrifying and audience this conspiracy
theory movie involves two documentary
filmmakers Aaron and Jim who set out to
learn about their favorite local
conspiracy theorists Terence when
Terence suddenly goes missing the pair
are drawn into the mystery of the Tarsus
Club an ancient cult comprised of world
leaders has been behind every major
event throughout history it's got the
ball rolling all of Terrence's dates
refer to specific meetings of the Tarsus
Club all of which take place right
before major world events the conspiracy
works in part because of theories it's
built upon are actually floating around
out there the shadow society that
controls the world it's a thing people
really believe in so the film carries a
sense of possibility the movie isn't
quite a documentary but we also wouldn't
be surprised if it turned out to
actually be one half supernatural
mystery half ghost story 2008 Lake Mungo
is a gripping tale of death grief and
secret lives
utilizing the tried and true based on a
true story horror hook this found
footage film tells the story of Alice
Palmer a 16 euro who drowns near her
family's home and then returns to haunt
them things aren't at all the way they
see and the truth of Alice's life may
have been a bigger mystery than her
death in spite of its catchy marketing
ploy Lake Mungo is a much better movie
than the average hunter its most
successful in his portrayal of Alice's
family who came across as legitimate and
authentic a real family in the midst of
the grieving process there's always the
question in the back of the mind
regarding the film's validity is it a
true story of course not but it doesn't
make its ending any easier to digest
when Daniel Marek and Eduardo Sanchez
went into the Blair Witch Project they
had no idea it would wind up having the
sort of impact it did the directors told
Bloody Disgusting in 2014 that their
biggest hope for the film was that it
would make it to video release in
reality it made it to Sundance and then
went on to usher in a slew of new found
footage films
including a not-so-great sequel in a
2016 remake the movie about three
filmmakers who go in search of a
legendary witch and find more than they
bargained for turned out to be one of
the most original and critically
acclaimed movies in this genre but it
came at a cost Merrick and Sanchez gave
their actors little to no information
going into the experience and over the
course of the Blair Witch projects
filming schedule they slowly deprived
them of food and sleep Merrick told
Bloody Disgusting Heather Donahue
thought she may have signed up for a
snuff film that fear comes through in
film making this one of the few found
footage films to genuinely feel like it
was edited together from real found
footage but perhaps the most successful
thing about the film is its ambiguity
it's really just a trio of campers in
the woods hearing noises and coming
across weird ritualistic totems The
Witches never seen and the ending is a
little confusing but sometimes the best
films are the ones that keep us guessing
check out our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]